[Music]
in diagnosing gonorrhea we are concerned
not only with the clinical and
epidemiologic evidence but laboratory
evidence as well all physicians however
may not be equipped for laboratory
diagnosis in such circumstances it is
wise to act on a provisional diagnosis
based on history and symptoms while
waiting for laboratory confirmation true
diagnosis rests on finding the
gonococcus by study of cultures and
smears or to use the word that is
gaining preference spreads since
facilities for culture study are not
available to all physicians many must
depend upon the spread alone in any case
our concern is to secure material for
laboratory study the Brooks discharge of
acute gonorrhea makes this a simple
routine matter both in the male and in
the female however a thick spread makes
very difficult so special care should be
taken to make the spread for gram
staining thin and uniform this is best
accomplished by rolling the material in
the manner shown here the story is quite
different in chronic gonorrhea in both
sexes when the profuse discharge is not
present then it is often extremely
difficult to secure material for study
yet here careful diagnosis is most
important chronic gonorrhea is a focus
of infection at a constant source of new
cases of gonorrhea as diagnosticians
we must be familiar with those
structures where the gonococcus may be
found and with the techniques for
stripping them in the mail these
structures that Harbor the gonococcus
are the urethra
the prostate Cowper's glands and the
seminal vesicles stripping these
structures will yield material for study
of course it is realized that procedures
for stripping these structures are
dangerous in the presence of acute
gonorrhea and that they belong only to
the chronic stage of the disease and
among the tests for cure stripping the
urethra is a simple and familiar
procedure the prostate however being
highly susceptible to trauma requires
gentle and correct massage the safest
and least painful method is to pass the
finger well up over the lateral lobe
bringing it down in a direction parallel
to the midline
after both lobes of us emptied the
finger is passed well up beyond the
median sulcus of the prostate and
brought several times from there to the
anterior extremity of the gland in this
form massage the dangers of
complications are reduced the patient's
comfort is perhaps the best guide as to
the degree of pressure to be used wisdom
will always err on the side of
gentleness topless glands through
manipulation may also yield material for
steady to find the gland the tip of the
finger is drawn down over the arch of
the pubic bone about 1/2 inch to the
side of the midline as it drops from the
edge of the bone it will particularly in
thin patients fall into a triangular
depression the gland is easily felt by
rolling the intervening tissues between
the finger and the thumb gently rolling
the tissue expressed the creature
lurking in the Glen the seminal vesicles
when stripped also provide material for
study however since the prosthetic
secretion always contains pus when the
seminal vesicles are infected it is
rarely necessary to strip them stripping
is resorted to when the second lightest
is suspected but the physician should
wait until the acute stage of the
disease is passed and a chronic stage
has been reached only then can digital
expression of the vesicles be done
safely to strip the vesicles extend the
finger beyond the prostate and to the
side of the midline and bring it
downward and toward the midline as shown
here
with the use of these techniques
material for spreads and cultures may be
obtained from the urethra the prostate
Cowper's glands and the seminal vesicles
secretions obtained by stripping any of
these glands are collected in sterile
broth for cultural studies and staying
for microscopic examination
of course preparation of the material
for laboratory study presents no problem
when the specimen is ample however
stripping the urethra the prostate and
calhfa's glands may at times yield only
a scanty discharge and in such cases the
following method may be used to prepare
material for study after stripping the
various structures secure the first half
ounce of urine voided
then centrifuge the urine
and in Beretta tube so that the urine
flows out leaving the sediment in the
tip of the tube
then place a very small amount of normal
salt solution in the tube
and shake well so that the sediment is
suspended in it
then centrifuge again
invert the tube and obtain sediment from
its tip for examination
this material is subjected to spread
examination and we're available culture
studies so much for the mail now to
secure material for study in chronic
gonorrhea in the female material may be
obtained from the urethra from the
endocervical glands and from skeins and
Bolin's plan
to secure material for study from the
urethra the urethral meatus is wiped
with cotton to remove vulva secretions
the glove finger is then inserted into
the vagina and urethra is stripped from
above down would the external meatus
being pressed rather firmly against the
pubic bone a small cotton wrapped
applicator is inserted about half an
inch into the urethra the applicator
should secure enough material for stain
and culture secretor from skeins blends
is expressed by the procedure just
described no additional massage or
manipulation is necessary in obtaining
secretor from Bothans glands first wipe
the area of the duct with cotton then
insert the index finger a short way into
the vagina and place the thumb on the
outer side of the labia majora the
intervening tissue is then gently
squeezed when secretion is obtained in
this way
it is usually too scary to be secured on
an applicator the flat end of a
toothpick or a platinum loop is better
suited for this purpose
in obtaining material from the cervix it
is well to remember that in the chronic
stage of the disease the gonococcus I
are deep in the endocervical glands and
usually not in the plug of mucous
filling the canal
thus it is best to cleanse this canal
with cotton held in a sponge forceps
then make firm pressure on the service
with blades of a bivalve speculum
and obtain the material thus expressed
for study if spreads of these secretions
are thin and uniform examination will be
facilitated if we rely on the techniques
described we will find that material for
test and study is always available all
of these materials from the male and the
female can of course be used both for
cultures and spreads
mastery of these techniques will help
provide laboratory evidence for
diagnosis and what is equally important
laboratory confirmation of cure but as
the laboratory checks the clinical
symptoms and general treatment so in the
case of chronic gonorrhea in the female
the clinical symptoms and case history
must be used as a check on the
laboratory this is necessary because in
chronic gonorrhea in women the
gonococcus will sometimes escape
detection by both the Gram stain and the
culture consequently when the history is
suspicious and symptoms persist the
laboratory must be challenged
perhaps repudiated in the case of the
female with chronic gonorrhea we must be
guided by epidemiologic and clinical
evidence as well as by laboratory
evidence if symptoms and history point
to the gonococcus
treatment is definitely in order
to withhold treatment is to risk new
infections and grave complications of
the patient
in any case the procedure of treating on
suspicion cannot be challenged we all
know patients who come from Germany
never return we know that often we have
a positive diagnosis from the laboratory
but no patient
to treat on suspicion to warn at once
that an infectious disease may be
present and to urge the patient to act
accordingly is to move toward gonorrhea
control
certainly we're infectious diseases are
concerned every physician feels that his
responsibility extends beyond his
patient it extends to the people the
patient may infect
since diagnosis is an integral part of
the patient's first visit and this first
encounter with a physician has a
profound influence on the patient's
later behavior it may be in order to
discuss further at this point the
patient and his doctor effective
venereal disease control and good case
holding rest on a doctor-patient
relationship and require that the
patient be considered is a total medical
problem the patient must be given an
understanding of the nature of his
problem and he must be given an
objective which will impel him to
continue treatment the patient may have
syphilis there may be other
complications certainly in a patient
we've got a real infection syphilis must
be considered ideally the history of
gonorrhea case follows these general
lines the patient usually comes to the
doctor's office three to six days after
exposure when the symptoms appear
following the examination the doctor
takes material for a spread he also
takes a blood test for syphilis as part
of the physical examination it is too
early to check for a syphilitic
infection which may have been contracted
when gonorrhea was contracted but the
doctor explains that the danger of such
an infection exists if possible the
doctor then gets the name of the contact
and speaks of bringing her under
treatment he also explains the nature of
the disease to the patient in language
that the patient can understand
the patient returns in three days for a
second examination and to learn the
laboratory findings let us assume that
the findings of the test for syphilis
are negative the smear however is
positive since treatment began with the
first visit the doctor now simply checks
the progress of the disease seven days
later the symptoms of most patients will
have vanished but now enough time they
ever lapsed for penile lesions to appear
if the patient also contracted syphilis
the doctor looks for lesions and if he
finds them does a dark field test at
once let us assume that no lesions are
found at this time the patient returns
again in seven days for two reasons so
that the doctor can check the gonorrhea
cure and look for penile lesions again
we assume that again no lesions are
found the patient returns and is
reexamined for infectious lesions at
weekly intervals for three weeks
thereafter every two weeks for another
six weeks a second blood test is part of
the final examination we have us
completed a three month period of
observation the course of action
described here has given the patient the
fullest possible protection his
gonorrhea cure has been determined the
physician is also determined whether or
not there was a syphilitic infection the
results are good case holding and
effective venereal disease control these
are objectives that must be attained we
know only too well that they will never
come to us from the laboratory but only
from an appreciation of human
relationships
when we speak of chemotherapy we speak
of the weapon with which a change in
history has been wrought we speak of a
swift sure and inexpensive cure for
gonorrhea chemotherapy in gonorrhea has
made difficult and painful local
treatment unnecessary accepting a small
number of patients who do not respond to
such medication it is a great boon to
the private physician the clinic
carrying heavy caseloads often with
extremely limited personnel and of
course it is a great boon to the patient
in discussing this new treatment it may
be well to recall an error of the test
in order to dispose of it permanently
for the future sulfanilamide was the
first selfi drug used in the treatment
of gonorrhea
although toxic reactions were frequent
and sometimes grave it continued in use
for a time because the better substitute
was not yet found because to tens of
thousands infected with gonorrhea it
offered the promise of a swift cure but
Swiss returned to the jobs which the
disease had taken them this early cell
phone amid compound held out a hope to
gonorrhea sufferers
but sulfanilamide produce toxic
reactions in many patients and created
numerous
a symptomatic carriers laboratories
focus their attention on finding a safer
and more effective chemo therapeutic
agent new sulfa drugs were produced
rapidly drugs the period itself an
element as these more effective drugs
appears leading finishings and the
United States Public Health Service
abandons elfin element but sulfanilamide
had been widely publicized and so it
gave waiver slowly to the more effective
safer drugs doctors continued to
prescribe it patients continued to ask
for it but there is no place for self an
element in the treatment of gonorrhea
today the drug of choice is
sulfathiazole but research and
experience indicates that it may be
entirely supplanted by penicillin the
toxicity of penicillin is negligible the
toxicity of sulfathiazole is low and the
reactions are mild rarely does a patient
find it impossible to consume enough of
the drug to bring about a cure even when
low blood concentrations are maintained
the relatively high cure rate is
achieved of course there are a few
people who cannot tolerate any of the
sulfa drugs in any concentration and so
all patients must be what this is no
drug to be sold over a counter without a
prescription 20 grams is a recommended
dosage for a single course of treatment
four grams a day for five days
however get this first course
sulfathiazole fails to bring about a
cure medication should be discontinued
for seven to ten days and then a second
course of treatment given a number of
patients will not be cured penicillin
should be considered penicillin therapy
of gonorrhea may mark or delay symptoms
of syphilis patient observation should
be continued over three months a special
precaution against transmitting a
possible chronic infection the physician
should insist that a condom be used at
every sexual contact for three months
after disappearance of symptoms with the
aid of these drugs we can in a short
time
make gonorrhea a comparatively rare
disease
prophylaxis is the other great ally of
gonorrhea control civilian and military
health authorities now recognize its
value and urge its widespread use to
make descriptions of approved techniques
available to physicians these
publications have been prepared and are
furnished on request the greatest safety
in preventive measures other than
continence belongs to the condom but
improper use of the condom destroys its
value
instruction of the patient is part of
the physicians role in implementing
prophylaxis common habits such as using
a condom only at the end of intercourse
should be condemned the patient should
also be warned to put on the condom
before his hand comes into contact with
a woman's genitalia lest he carry the
infection to his own organs before
intercourse is begun these and other
points need to be impressed on the
patient a pamphlet shown is intended for
lay education and can also be secured
from the United States Public Health
Service the prophylactic packet is
sometimes effective but here again a
patient needs instruction as to its
proper use chemical prophylaxis is most
effective when administered in the
medical supervision when administered
soon after exposure it is at least 90%
effective prophylactic measures are not
as easily applied in women nor are they
considered to be as efficacious there is
no doubt that widespread use of
prophylaxis will aid materially in
controlling gonorrhea education to the
public so that people will not go to the
quack but for the like each physician
barely diagnoses by the physician
correct use of prophylaxis
papayas old penicillin please save our
weapons in the hands of the medical
profession and most important in
gonorrhea therapy let us remember this
the laboratory is not infallible
clinical and epidemiologic findings are
ample grounds for tweets if we use them
as a basis for treatment we will
eradicate many infections that in the
past filtered through the diagnostic net
certainly sulfathiazole and penicillin
are a promise and a challenge to the
medical profession an opportunity to
wipe out one of our oldest diseases and
an opportunity to save millions of man
days lost to industry and the armed
force to prevent a great loss to the
nation's health and strength
[Music]